hey guys it's Justine and today I'm
gonna go through my top 5 favorite
features in iOS 14 this is a beta
version and obviously if you do have a
developer's account you'll have access
to the beta versions of software it is
recommended you do not install this on
your main devices it is beta there's
still bugs it is still new software that
they're working to release later on this
year so since I do have a developer's
account I do have it running on one of
my other phones and I'm so excited to
show this to you guys my number one
favorite new feature is messages they
have a bunch of new updates to the
messages app my favorite though is the
fact that you can now pinned messages
now this is a group chat with Farook and
Jenna I named them fun friends you can
go into this you can change the photo
you can change the name I'm shooting a
video so now let's go down here and I'm
gonna change this to a shrimp I'm making
a video about our group here on iOS 14
now I'm gonna add Farook so I'll be
alerting Farook that I am tagging him in
this message Jenna doesn't currently
have iOS 14 yet so she's not even gonna
be able to see this did you see this
cool mention feature and there it is
it'll highlight his name and you can
also go in and add in line so you can
reply in the texts to direct messages so
if you're going to have a ton of chats
happening you can do this look at me
reply in line Jenna I can't cuz she's
lame I can reply to Jenna though you'll
see this line connects this chat
together and if I just want to see that
conversation I can click on the reply
and that will bring up just that inline
chat so this is gonna help so much when
you're having group conversations with
people I'm really excited about that so
when I go back to messages you'll see
that Jenna just posted a new message in
that thread she says I'm living in the
past you can see Jenna's little icon
it's so cool next up we have new meme oh
jeez I'm so excited I absolutely love
MIMO jeez I'm such a huge fan so I'm
gonna make my new meme og here and I'm
gonna put some nice blush on my cheeks
because I'm always overdoing it beauty
spa so I have one right here I still
need to move the beauty spot over I feel
like you should be able to adjust that
hairstyles
there are so many different hairstyles
let's do I just know what does my hair
even look like I don't like that do we
kind of have some highlights oh my gosh
they do have a gradient this is
incredible so they have new aging
options here so you can make yourself
older or younger I wear so you don't
wear glasses and lost I'm reporting a
podcast so if I did I usually have blue
ones so like there I am and now for the
face covering there we go I'm usually
wearing a black mask I think that's it
cool I'm gonna send a message to Jenna
hey Jenna I just wanted to remind you to
wear your face mask
okay cooled five what happens if I stick
my tongue out that nothing okay see ya
my next favorite thing is the new
addition to widgets so you can add
different widgets in the widget gallery
so you can search for all sorts of
things you can make it really cool smart
stack here so you can add a bunch of
different things into this and they can
be flipped through easily so we're gonna
add this widget so here's our stack now
we can change this and we can put this
on the front page as I have my calendar
right here so if I want to move that
around
I mean imagine this like if I put my
battery on my front homescreen we don't
want that I am always looking at the
weather it's gonna go in and I'm going
to edit this budget and I can pick my
location and as soon as that's chosen I
can just take this and I can also put
this on my home screen as well there's
also the new app library which kind of
goes hand-in-hand with us this will give
you a nice organized look at all of your
apps so it automatically will organize
everything into categories still see we
have our utilities productivity social
and all of these things are
automatically filtered into folders like
I did this before on my phone on my
actual phone that I use daily and it was
the most absurd thing ever because it
took me so long to do that and then I
kind of gave up and all my apps just
ended up wherever they wanted to be I
know I said messages was my number one
favorite feature but I also am very
excited
about picture-in-picture here's the
trailer for one of the new Apple TV
shows so you can just click right here
this gives you the picture and picture
options I can move this around wherever
I want I can go into my notes so I can
still be working on my notepad hello I
am love you I am writing and watching
etrailer oh this is gonna be so awesome
and then if I fling it down at the
bottom it stays off to the side so I can
still hear the audio but the video I
won't be able to see so I just kind of
pull that video back out from the arrow
button and I can put it wherever I want
that's so great picture-in-picture it's
here this will also work on your iPad
too so it cannot wait I'm actually kind
of excited to see this Apple TV show as
well let me know in the comments below
what you're most looking forward to in
iOS 14 these are some of my favorites
and I cannot wait until these are
finally rolled out into the wild
during iPhone season which will be here
before we know it thank you guys so much
for watching be sure to subscribe and be
sure to hit the bell so you'll be alert
when I release a new video I'll also put
a link in the description where you can
subscribe to our podcast and we have a
special WWDC episode up right now so go
check it out and I will see you guys in
the next video bye
[Music]